[Music]
what are you guys doing here
what am I doing here well I came out to
just practice hooking up the three-point
attachments that's not crazy you guys
don't do that in your spare time huh
well since you're here you want me to
show you some tips all right let's get
into it all right I apologize I think
quarantine has me going a little crazy
but I do want to show you some tips on
how to hook up attachments to your
three-point hitch and maybe we'll get
one or two in there on the PTO as well
but should be a good overview and as I
usually do I learn some things simply by
looking in the manual a little bit
harder than I normally do so you know
let's go ahead and go through this will
give you a good lay of the land here on
how to have everything set up properly
at least my interpretation of it you
know your mileage may vary as they say
but I want to give you some advice here
because it could make your life a lot
easier I absolutely used to hate hooking
up the three-point attachments but it's
pretty much a piece of cake anymore so
I've got several tractors here and
that's intentional you know I want to
give you some different setups here some
different versions that you can see
because all the tractors are different
out there and this doesn't clearly
represent everything that's gonna be on
the market but it gives you a good idea
and a good basic understanding so we do
have a forty sixty six R right here
gonna have a thirty thirty nine are
right here and then a twenty thirty two
R as well over there and you can't see
it in this footprint right here but I do
have my 10 25 R as well we might get
that into the mix also I've talked about
this rate of drop or speed of drop
control before which is essentially
opening and closing a valve that's gonna
be tied into your three-point hitch or
your rock shaft control system and
looking in the manual surprisingly it's
underneath the section of attaching and
detaching your three-point-four asian
all that kind of thing
surprisingly it says you want to set
this so that it takes two seconds to
lower to the ground otherwise you could
you know potentially damage or injure or
whatever else you know so good note
there to in or two seconds to get all
the way down to the ground from a fully
raised position that means it's gonna
have to be almost completely closed
maybe just a hair backed off from that
but I'll show you what I mean so I've
got this valve completely closed right
now I'm gonna pack it off just a little
bit and we'll see how long it takes to
lower
what was that like three seconds three
and a half seconds
open it a little more
that's about two seconds right there
okay so while we're out here looking at
the 1025 R I want to take a quick second
show you how to make attaching to this
PTO shaft that much easier so if you
have a machine that's equipped with both
a mid and a rear pto what I want you to
do is go ahead and take your PTO lover
here okay this is your PTO select lever
it's going to control which PTO you're
operating whether it's the rear the mid
or both at the same time so I've gone
ahead and moved my PTO select shaft to
the rear PTO alright and so that means
that if I had this machine on and pulled
out the the knob for the PTO or flipped
a button that the rear PTO would be
spinning and engaged okay say I had a
tiller or a brush hog attached so if I
come back here and try to spin this PTO
shaft it's not gonna spin you can hear
it kind of rattling as it's locked in
place there so now if I move this PTO
lever to the mid PTO position okay so
only the mid PTO was running and it
would not be the rear PTO if I had the
machine on let's go ahead and see what
happens see how it freely spins so if I
move this back to the to the rear there
we go it's gonna be locked in place if I
move it back to the mid it's gonna
freely move and that will help you align
your splines that are on your PTO shaft
with the splines that are on here on the
output shaft on the tractor
hey and as we go through this video
today keep your eyes on these quick
itches here because I'll get to it later
in the video but if you think that this
sounds like a major chore attach and
detach them from the three-point hitch
then you might find that a quick hitch
is what you need and if you haven't done
so yet hit that subscribe button below
right there underneath the video hit
subscribe make sure you read the
description a lot of links a lot of good
information down there as well and go to
good works tractors com2 would love to
help you with a tractor or an attachment
delivery and financing as well you know
to set your tractor up right on your
three-point hitch it's actually a little
bit more involved than you might think
and if you've ever wondered why there's
three positions up here well so today so
finally what do you know I looked into
it a little bit further and these three
different positions totally mean
something okay there's a reason for
those so let's go through it so before
we actually hook up to the three-point
hitch it's important to know which pin
position you should put your top leg
okay you're sent a link right here and
this all mean something different these
three different locations now not every
tractor has three locations but for
those that do there's a reason for it I
have to break off the manual to show you
let's take a quick peek okay this is a
John Deere 2032 our 2038 manual we are
opening to our positioning center leaks
links section right here and you're
gonna see for light and medium loads
install Center link and the bottom hole
B okay down here medium and heavy loads
see ok the middle one for very heavy
draught loads D the top one okay also
notice you're gonna see a category one
implement hey there mister fly tilts
forward while raising in this position
category I wanna implement tilts forward
varies slightly while raised in this
position and category one raises but
angle remains constant okay so important
note there depending on the tool that
you're using I can't believe that fly is
just doing what he wants I get
distracted too easy anyway pay attention
to that because that can mean something
could mean a difference to the implement
that you're using and hooking up to your
three-point hitch okay so the first
thing that you need to do is gonna be to
put your tractor in park turn that
sucker off for the initial hookup okay
so we may need to turn the machine on it
at a certain point in time here but get
your tractor off get it in park in
neutral that kind of thing so safety
first as always I want to make sure
that's above and beyond everything else
that we do next thing after that you're
gonna see I am on a completely level
section of ground here you know that's
gonna make your life so much easier you
know there's a point in time when I had
a lot of attachments stored in my back
yard and it has just a slight slope you
know it's not significant it's enough to
notice but it's nothing crazy and I
always used to Park attachments in the
back edge of my lawn on my yard there
along that slope and it was just a
nightmare to constantly hook those
things up and detach them and everything
else and I just absolutely hated it so
if you can park on a piece of level
ground your attachments it's gonna make
life so much easier next thing you're
gonna see I do have all my attachments
typically gonna be stored on a pallet
and that's for a couple of reasons one
you know you can move them around easier
if you need to move them from point A to
point B if they're already on a pallet
and set up and ready to go it's a lot
easier that way
- it gets that attachment a little bit
higher off the ground it's not fun you
know the older you get the less you want
to be bent down hunkered over and
everything else so you know even the
four or five inches that you see here
makes a big difference the other reason
that I find a pallet useful is because
on a machine like my forty sixty six are
the three-point hitch doesn't always
drop down far enough to allow like the
quick hitch for instance here to release
from underneath these pins and so if I
have an elevator a little bit higher and
makes that process a lot easier
so there's several reasons there to use
pallets or something else to raise up
your attachments it's also nice just to
keep them off the ground from moisture
corrosion that kind of thing as well you
know so it's much easier to focus on one
point rather than trying to focus here
and here and here all three points you
know so the biggest thing that I try to
do when I'm backing up to an implement
is lining up the center link with the
top pin position here on the three-point
hitch don't worry so much about the
sides down here as long as you feel like
you're pretty square it's gonna come out
all right you'll be able to have enough
adjustment there typically or you can
get on the tractor and slightly go back
further or forward after you have one
pin attached focus on the center link
getting it aligned up here in the middle
because that way you know your spacing
is correct and your top link is correct
as well typically what I like to do is
start out with my three-point hitch as
low as possible and then I'll raise it
down up from there so let's go ahead and
get that done now and this is something
you can do with the tractor off in the
park position so if it's not in the
lowest position right now you can just
go ahead and move that rock shaft lever
all the way down and it'll naturally do
its thing if there's nothing on the
three-point arms for example then you
might just need to give it a little bit
of a push in order to encourage you to
go down but it will go down okay
I should probably open up this rated rap
a little bit more now if you're lucky
enough to have a model of tractor that
has this style of sway arm down here
okay with just a pin where you can pull
it out and position it in different
areas now is the time that I would say
to release those do it on this side as
well see how much flexibility that gives
you the other style is gonna be this
turnbuckle style of sway arm down here
as well typically once they're set up
there's not going to be a whole lot of
adjustment that's required but there is
a tightening nut on here or sometimes a
pin that goes through to hold this
little Center link in place you undo
that and then you can loosen it up and
it'll shorten this gap here or lengthen
it out to give you more adjustment that
way so at this point here I'm just going
to go ahead and back up to it and what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna attach these
lower links first and so as I'm backing
up you can see you can pick up on on the
the arms here okay and so I'm gonna keep
them just slightly lower than what the
elevation is here and then once I get
back here I'm gonna attach the lower
link first whatever one appears to be
just slightly lower I know it's level
ground but there's still gonna be one
that's probably not perfectly level you
know so I'm gonna put the lower one on
first and then if I need to I can lift
up I can turn the machine on lift up
just slightly and get the other side
link to match up and slide over the pin
so you can see at this point we're just
about there all right and with an
attachment that's a little bit lighter
like this you can actually just kind of
scoot it forward a little bit you know
and get it into place there if you
needed to you could actually just have
it go right underneath those pins
completely and then you can pull out to
the side you see how they're gonna go
out to the side a little bit and give
yourself some more room that way so what
I'm gonna do in this situation is just
scoot it slightly forward here get these
pins off of here throw it over there and
now let's lift up you can see how I'm
just lifting up just like that and we'll
just give it a little jiggle and it's on
so to make the connection over on this
second lower pin over here I'm gonna go
ahead and turn the machine on just a
little bit and raise it up so that way
this arm is raising a touch to slide
over here easier
and I'm guessing that's all that's gonna
be needed give it a little jiggle like
that and I have this here just in case
because feel free you know if you just
need a centimeter more or whatever else
give a little whack like that and that's
no problem at all
put that lower link there now we're on
to the top link here so with the top
link here you're gonna see it is
adjustable got this locking or Jam nut
on here too so if it is tightened down
you're not gonna be able to lengthen out
this side once it's attached but you can
loosen that up too and then we'll get
this attached and you'll see that
sometimes if these don't have any grease
on him they're a little stiff okay so
you have two ways that you can level
this three-point attachment out okay so
first is you're gonna have your top link
that will level this way okay or pitch
if you want something to you know to get
a more aggressive dig or line if you
want or to have it ride a little bit
more smoothly and evenly all the way
across so depends on the attachment that
you have on how you want it set up by
giving that angle or levelness forward
to backwards is gonna be with the top
link here now what gives you level
side-to-side okay this way in this way
is gonna be with these two arms here and
that's so much with this arm over here
but you are gonna have adjustment right
here in this arm and so in the same way
that you can adjust a top link you know
you can put your set of channel locks or
wherever else on here and you can rotate
this and adjust it along this threaded
rod here to either level it out if you
want or if you want to say you're
grading with a with a back blade or a
box weight or something else and you
want one side to dig in more for
instance you can offset it that way to
allow for that to happen what you will
see on some fancier setups like this one
here are gonna be a little bit of an
easier adjustment that you can make with
this contraption right here whatever you
want to call it and so but a little bit
you're that way to do and you can just
slot it right back down in there and
make that adjustment a little bit easier
but let me show you an even easier way
yet okay so yeah this is definitely as
easy as you can get it all right and so
this is also the most expensive way
there's no doubt about it but it is
pretty cool so I wanted to show it to
you you know there's a there's a lot of
money that's tied up in something like
this set up here because you need to
have two functions okay like a fourth
and a fifth remote right here dedicated
to operating the setup in addition to
that you have to buy you know your
hydraulic top link here and your
hydraulic side link over here so instead
of having to mess with the monkeying
around you know manually threading the
rods in and out and trying to get a
level and everything else you can simply
after you have this whole system set up
you know use a couple levers right from
your operator station and make those
adjustments on the fly or if you need to
if you're detaching from one and then
going up to hook up to another one even
on those uneven surfaces because you can
just simply angle your you're quick
hedge here or your three-point hitch
this way for instance and then hook up
to it level it out and away you go now
the other really cool feature found on
the 4-hour series and I think some
larger series as well is called hitch
assist and with this knob right here I
can raise and lower the three-point
hitch from right back here off the
operator seat and with these functions
right here I can actually move the
tractor slowly forward or backwards to
just allow it to slowly creep backwards
and hook up or slowly go forwards and
hook up that way with or without a quick
edge doesn't matter if it's just the
three-point arms itself or a quick hitch
either way I have done an entire video
on this system and how to operate it
I'll post a link above but I don't want
to spend too much time going through the
ins and outs of it right now you know so
if you think that hooking up to a
three-point hitch is a real pain in the
butt then you're not alone and that's
why these quick hitches have become so
popular with everybody you can't
actually do any work with it but it
takes so much of the frustration and
just the horribleness about hooking up
to a three point attachment out of that
process so I'm gonna go ahead and show
you really quick here how to put one of
these on once it's on it's on right so
it's good for any attachment you just
hook and unhook as needed and it's just
a lot simpler process
I can sell one of these to you as well I
can even ship them for a really
reasonable rate so go ahead and get a
hold of me and go to good works tractors
comm and check them out they're gonna
come with three pins here all the
hardware you need to hook them up and
these quick hitches are built to a
standard a SAE specification which is
just a dimensional spacing requirement
for quick hitches and for quick hitch
compatible attachments it can make it
easier for some of the heavier ones like
this is a pretty heavy footage here you
know if you want to have another person
helping you out but otherwise once you
get it on there it's pretty
straightforward
it's just a matter managing it all by
yourself your top link in here and boom
there you go you do have adjustments
here for the top hook okay so you can
see the different positions you can
raise it up and down if you need to in
there you know these are just spring
loaded on the arms here again you do
need a set of bushings for every
attachment that you put that you plan to
hook up to your quick hitch here but
really sweet piece of equipment here
again you can't do any work with it
specifically but man it makes work more
efficient and more enjoyable
so really quick just go over how to hook
up a three-point hitch attachment or the
rear shaft of a three-point hitch
attachment to your rear pto you can see
there's the splines in there okay and
these simply it's just like a keys just
got to fit right with the splines that
are on the back of your tractor the
output shaft there for the rear pto and
so typically what you need to do after
you get to a certain point you're gonna
have a little button like this or you're
gonna have a collar to pull back okay
it's gonna help it seat on there and
then lock into place so it doesn't fly
off while you're actually using the
implement you'll be able to get the
shaft on partway but then before you get
it the whole way you're gonna have to
hit that button there or again pull the
collar back to get it to go all the way
on and then pull back a little bit get
it to seat you'll be good to go so this
is gonna be the collar style instead of
that little push button you just have a
collar to pull back on and so same thing
when you're releasing the pto chef and
you want to take it off the tractor you
got to either pull back on that collar
or we have to push on that button and
then pull back at the same time okay
same concept for a mid pto as well for
you folks with mower decks so I'm a
pretty realistic guy I know that a
hydraulic top and tilt kit and this
whole setup here is just not gonna
happen for most of us you know it's just
a cool thing it's it's the cat's meow
you know the creme de la creme the kind
of the best setup you can get for that
the worst setup is your traditional
three-point hitch right so a good middle
ground there and actually a pretty
reasonable price point is gonna be that
quick hitch there if that's the route
you want to go I can definitely help you
out with it again go to good works
tractors comm I can ship them to you if
you're not too far away you know seven
eight nine hundred miles I can ship them
really cheap and not a whole lot more
even a little bit further than that so
don't hesitate to reach out I'd love to
help you out with one of those another
attachment as well if you haven't done
so yet hit that subscribe button below
right down below there make sure you
check out all those links head on over
to the Amazon store go to good works
komm stay safe we'll see you soon